calm and focused a last training session
before the biggest moment of their
sporting careers
england know they need to overturn
history to win their first ever major
title it's a fairy tale a fairy tale
fixture with the history behind it but i
think for us
uh you would never expect to get to a
final without playing
the best team in the tournament and as
you know in terms of i think the journey
that both of us have been on you've got
the two two teams that have had the best
tournaments in the final which is the
best thing
a formidable opponent if germany win
this will be their ninth title an
unbeaten run in a euro final
we're just glad to be allowed to be here
to have this privilege we've dreamed of
to play a final against england at
wembley i don't know if there will be or
have been many bigger moments in sport
for our players
well when you read the final
then you're one of the best teams in the
tournament i think we have a very good
team too and we don't fear anyone
what have we got that they haven't do
you think
the home crowd the home card i think
i think if you speak to the germans what
they would want tomorrow is to have a
crowd like we've got
last year the men's final was
overshadowed by violent scenes as a
result ahead of the women's final
security has been beefed up here robust
measures are in place this will all be a
no drinking zone around the stadium and
on the ground there'll be a larger
police and security presence seem to be
getting on with it and
showing the men the right way to do
things i just see it as a football game
a normal football game as well i don't
think it really matters who plays
the team sized up the pitch and took a
few moments to enjoy it their dreams and
that of the nation so close
adele robinson sky news